le politologue camerounais est léon
koungou spécialiste en relations
internationales africaines appelle à une
réforme profonde du système politique
nigérian concrètement au fait un début
octobre il est question de dénoncer les
violences policières notamment les
délits de violence perpétrés par l'unité
spéciale de la police en charge de lutte
contre les braquages
vous vous souvenez qu'en 2014 amnesty
international avait déjà publié un
rapport qui était intitulé bienvenue en
enfer où on dénonce les tortues les
exécutions extrajudiciaires de cette
brigade
aujourd'hui les mains les manifestants
veulent une meilleure représentation des
religieux dans la sphère politico
administratives mais aussi une
augmentation des salaires et la création
des emplois et qui n'est pas facile
parce que nos pays et durablement et la
pandémie du clonage et russes mais aussi
la chute du cours du baril de pétrole
sur le marché international faut que la
réforme de l'état et des régions
les manifestants appellent à une réforme
structurelle de la police il faut une
police de proximité factures qu'ils
puissent convenablement encadrer les
manifestations les aussi il faut une
véritable séparation des pouvoirs parce
que s'il n'y a pas de véritable contre
pouvoir à l'exécutif
et s'il n'y a pas de véritable relais
séparation de pouvoir les contre
pouvoirs vont s'exprimer dans paris